closed buildings and boarded up windows
have long been depressing sites in some
of the nation's urban areas but recently
some saw that blight and a home as a
giant canvas that could be used to bring
important messages to the community they
enlisted the help of local artists to
deliver vital health information related
to the kovat 19 pandemic and most
recently they watched as America's
latest crisis became another source of
urgent artistic expression I like this
one better because you're looking out
for yourself and others community
activists are Neda curry in March strand
twists broke in a new campaign message
here we go when kovat 19 broke out thank
you in North Philadelphia partnering
with other members in the 37th Ward
they're spreading messages they find are
helpful to their neighbors messages of
survival the message needed now is trust
what you're hearing because it's real
and folks don't trust they hear
conflicting versions of what this is and
it's so simple this cobalt is serious
curry knows just how serious I mean this
was close to home for you very close
very close the end of March
my sister had contracted it she was in a
coma for four weeks that's as long as we
had her and we lost them fill the walls
with hope his strand Quist answer a way
to bring informative possibly even
life-saving images to businesses
shuttered by the pandemic as an artist a
boarded up business could also be a
blank canvas gives us one of the rare
and unique mediums where we can
literally dream of a world that doesn't
exist this art this is a gesture this is
not the solution it's one of many things
that all of us can be doing in this
moment to help each other out
the project can be seen here at the
village of Arts and Humanities a
community center serving the Germantown
neighborhood this neighborhood which is
incredibly disinvested for over a
half-century they know how important it
is to get positive hopeful and also
informative material out to the public
and Aviva caboose runs the center which
now provides a unique view we wanted to
make sure that the environment that
people are coming into was one that was
filled with color and filled with
positive messages and look more like a
gallery than a you know social service
center created by a diversity of artists
these posters yard signs banners and
decals aren't just going up here but all
across Philadelphia at City Hall 10,000
people a week line up by decal space 6
feet apart to collect meals during the
crisis we're the largest program of its
kind anywhere I think in the world
that's really great Jayne golden runs
mural arts Philadelphia and funded this
project because it coalesced with some
of her own you know what here's the
thing about Kovan it is shining a light
on issues that existed before Kovach for
more than 30 years she's listened for
ways to fill that need through her
mission the fact that you place the
mural right next to a hand-washing when
we got the call from the Broad Street
ministry they said we want to do
hand-washing stations but we want to
call attention to the hand-washing
station we want to have art behind the
station so we were like oh that's such a
brilliant idea
but just as people were solving one
problem the world changed covin 19 took
a backseat
[Music]
to the anger and outrage over the
killing of George Floyd and so many
others but something else also emerged
new messages a new visual expression and
down came murals of the past that had
already been deemed divisive the Frank
Rizzo he's the prominent likeness of a
former mayor
some say turned a blind eye to police
brutality Russ public art is about
community it's bringing people together
it had to go we have to really listen to
what's going on talk to activists and
artists making sure we create platforms
for black artists artists of color like
more than we were doing like do it with
more intention
but in Germantown the same morning we
returned two months later
half a block away from the village
buildings were ablaze no protesters in
sight these businesses may never open
again neighborhood yep and for residents
like Arnett occur that's changed the
scope of her mission and like this whole
mural project this whole notion of
trying to get a message out to stay safe
where is that gone and topics is still
there and the protest the protest served
a lot of things Avenue to release a
coverage to cover you up where you would
be out in open or this protestor travel
around the world that means something I
seen this before I seen change happen
I'm praying that it's fixed this time so
so privileged to have been able to see
this conversation happening in real time
often we watch it after the fact so glad
we had a chance to go back and revisit
that community and see what they were
doing as this next step occurred and
Michelle it's a little thing but the
power of art and those messages you may
not even realize it as you're taking it
in but really a beautiful story and a
wonderful way to try to get some of
those messages out